unlike everybody thanks for joining in
I'm so Hayden we're live broadcasting
from new delhi india's capital and I'm
for 80-plus al Jazeera's digital channel
so if you see this contingent of police
here
so there is a student Perez happening
dozens of students with just rounded up
in two buses by the police so more
protesters will be coming in
many claim that it has been a turbulent
year for India new universities and
campuses student community has been
protesting always issues in different
campuses of India the latest one being a
student leader in one of the india's
premier diversities j and you was
arrested he's in charge of sloganeering
NT india remarks during a protest
session the student union held in the
campus the people are coming on the
streets saying it's an assault on
descent or it's an assault on the
freedom of expression let's talk some
folks and see what's happening most of
the students who were here protesting
have been rounded up by police just a
short while back we have dr omar khan
pair he's a he's a Dalit scholar and
activist hi doctor dr. makanya we're
broadcasting light or international
audience can you share what just
happened here and what are these possess
all about see this protest is about the
crackdown on campuses in India right now
we're college students and other
students are being targeted for not
toeing the line of the Hindu politics
and it's highly unwanted action by the
police they have no business to stop
people from protesting against the
injustices that have been meted out to
students whether it is Jane you or
hyderabad central university or the
other pure university or Allahabad even
city or banaras hindu ero city or even
for that matter several other university
campuses students are rising about you
know several ensues it is not just a
question of some deletes or adivasi
students being discriminated against but
there are many other isms on which they
have been mobilizing students and
and in this dispensation which is like
you know a right-wing government right
now in India they are trying to impose
their own fascist culture but somewhere
ask if this is an issue happening inside
a campus why is it spilling onto the
streets of Delhi that's mainly because
you know these right-wing organizations
are calling in first people from outside
to speak against their students in front
of these university campuses so in a way
students are also coming unto streets
not only to so their anger but also to
demand you know society at large because
there is a sinister campaign to brand
these students as aunt innocence so they
are coming on to streets to say that no
we are not aunt innocence we are like
any other Indian citizen we are also
demanding our rights which has been
enshrined in the Constitution of India
that is there is nothing wrong in
demanding rights I mean that way there
is a glorious history of student
movement in this country and and they
have always we have always fought
against the dictatorial governance we
have a question from a viewer he is
asking that his has any politician
really visited the University where this
issue is happening oh yes yes definitely
I mean even Rahul Gandhi came to the
campus and several other leaders
including
the Delhi Chief Minister Arvind Kejriwal
and plus several other leaders not only
from political organization but also
from several social organizations they
have been visiting they are from farmers
organization they all have been visiting
and sewing their solidarity with the
students here yesterday are the march at
jantar mantar also there were several
political leaders who came and I think I
think some boos two in sylvania coming
like this with us let's hope that way I
thought that way and see what's
happening dude it's really a sad
situation that in your own country you
cannot even noticed so what has happened
like short while back dozens of students
were rounded up by police in buses yes
I'm their incentive are there most of
the protest is dispersed now yes so and
that that's that's really sad you know
it because you know in a democracy if
you do not have a right to protest that
clearly shows that the Indian state is
becoming a police state you cannot
unleash foolish on your
this is highly undemocratic action by
the local police delhi police and and
somebody should be held accountable for
this otherwise otherwise India cannot
claim that it is a democratic country I
think there are a lot of people the
quality is also expected to come hey
viewers if you could see police is
rushing to this under the spot of
protesters there and seems likely that
they might also be rounded up because
police I mean hasn't been allowing the
protest yes happen here so this is not a
prohibited zone how can you you know who
was you like this area
there's a lot of media contingent
covering this issue as well the issue of
the friction between what might call
what some might call the friction
between different scene bodies in India
and the present government vgt let
government is not going fine so this is
a series of protests that has happened
like last couple of weeks the mother of
Roy tremula is the mother of Rohit Rohit
the gemmaluna was dull it's cool scholar
he committed suicide last month
apparently because he was there was an
assault in his University on his freedom
of expression and he was allegedly not
getting his stipend because the Dalit
scholars young women are like that is
what other Daleks father because of the
dollar scholars in his University had an
issue with the right-wing student body
in the University and which compel as
different newspaper report suggests
which compel the University stop his
stipend and ultimately led to his
suicide so that issue has really
generated a lot of traction in the
country and now Roe hits a mother is
here on a media contingent as you can
see are talking to her
please
the Dalits are be under privileged class
India in society and bargain is divided
into different cars there are higher
costs and there are lower costs and
lower costs get reservation in jobs and
and subsidized spooling so ballots are
from the lower costs but as activists
say in most cases what happens is lower
costs tend to get pushed to the wall
some might say they get marginalized and
Roy bambola who committed suicide was
one of the students from the lower cars
as you might see police is not allowing
people to gather here and most of the
students who came here to protest have
been rounded up in buses and there are
some more here and a media contingent is
talking to them
let's try to top some students there
aren't many here they having rounded up
but they're up will
dusting this potential audience can you
say tell me what's happening here
actually thing is that we are seeing the
description is there listo force is not
a language to put canvases they're
saying it they don't have any permission
and if there is a case of on any journal
thing they'll allow us even the cockpit
so this is happening they are not
allowing us it has me not wonder they
can use what you also if you do
something using the police can use
Beaton's as well yes they can don't
press them actually what are the issues
that you think student community has
it's pretty clear nowadays it's a basic
thing first of all discrimination then
prom in my third concept in society
still exist in society and that's the
row eight is one of the best example in
recent example
alrighty but cement yeah there's a lot
of whose contingent here as you can see
there's a hoarding sex so a group of
protesters has finally managed to sit in
they haven't allowed to sit in for a
while and we have to see how long this
will go we're couple more people here
and i'll try to ask them couple of
questions as to how things are shaping
on
right I'm broadcasting live for
al-jazeera so our viewers are asking us
like what do students basically war why
are the protest by the best thing it was
me testing as you know with Lamela
research scholar rated see was what is
we understand it to be an institutional
murder which is the thing that the
university in a sense is a space which
is supposed to understand the unequal
backgrounds from which people come and
create a platform creator space where
people are treated as equals in ruins
case it was very clear that
institutionally the university reflected
the inequalities of society and punished
him many tend to suggest if the year has
been a year of nudity mutinies in
different campuses of india why do you
think that is it is it's the answer at
one level is pretty simple and mother is
quite complicated the simple answer is
that there are different political
tendencies a different political
tendencies and the indian political
space and certainly regressive
right-wing tendencies are on the rise so
mr. spaces are not spaces where these
things will be taken
no by others lying down but as you might
see people are now demanding justice and
wanting freedom of expression and you
may concern is that there has been
growing assault on dissent in the
universities and campuses in any gear
Oh
alright guys will be signed off in a
couple of minutes the process is ongoing
the students and now lit candles they'll
try to sit for a candlelight vigil if
the police allows them it seems like we
finally have been allowed to hold a
sit-in
now here in Delhi near the india gate
near this landmark india gate
Oh